Johnathan's in Kentucky where is the
best place to put my emergency fund my
bank offers many types of savings
accounts I want to make sure the money
is available when I need it well it
needs to be fully liquid meaning that
you can get to it with no penalties
that's all that matters
really it's not gonna earn much no
matter what you do with it your
emergency fund is not an investment your
emergency fund is insurance investments
make you money insurance protects the
things that make you money so it's not
an investment it's insurance and so when
you set ten fifteen twenty thousand
dollars aside for your rainy day fund
and it's sitting in a stupid savings
account making 1% that costs you money
cuz you could have been investing it in
something good right
that cost is called opportunity costs
missed opportunity but that's okay you
do it anyway you have a rainy day fund
but its purpose is not to build wealth
your other investments your other money
actually builds your wealth
this protects the things that build
wealth here's an example let's say the
transmission goes out on your car and
you have no money but you put all your
money in your 401k because you're all
about investing now how you gonna fix a
car well you're either gonna put it on a
credit card which will be stupid
or even dumber than that you're gonna
borrow on your 401k that be stupid or
you're gonna cash out your 401k that'd
be really stupid because that's gonna
cost you a 10% penalty plus your tax
rate of thirty five percent or whatever
it is and so you got a thirty five or
forty percent hit on your money that's
like borrow money thirty percent
interest to fix your car because you
didn't have a rainy day fund because you
know what it's gonna rain Dave you need
to be positive I'm positive it's gonna
rain you need to be ready it's coming
and so that emergency fund is not making
you money but it protects you from doing
something stupid when bad things happen
I didn't say if bad things happen I said
when you're gonna lose a job there's
going to be a car wreck there
gonna be a surgery there's gonna be a
dot dot dot fill in the blank right
that's just life I'm not being negative
I'm interest happens and when you have
money it turns a quote-unquote emergency
into an inconvenience thirty years ago
almost Sharon and I were so broke we
couldn't pay attention we were on the
verge of bankruptcy at that point and a
little baby and a toddler in the house
and a woman stressed out of her mind
because her husband was a doofus and had
gotten so far in debt we couldn't see
this was not a pretty pictures August in
Tennessee now if you don't know about
August in Tennessee you can cut the
humidity here with a knife and stuck it
in blocks okay
I mean it gets hot and humid you can't
breathe little baby's stressed out
mommy's and the air conditioner goes out
right on cue we had no money none they
were on the verge of bankruptcy already
the air conditioner goes that we gon do
well I don't know what you're supposed
to do I know what I did okay I got a guy
from the church as a friend of mine that
had a bunch of junk in his backyard one
piece of which was a air compressor for
the compressor which is what had gone
out and you know we got some stuff from
Home Depot when over there welded that
thing in he said he sort of knew what he
was doing and then we had a heat and air
guy who actually didn't know what he's
doing come over and charged the thing up
I ended up let me tell 30 years ago and
I remember what it cost it's three
hundred twenty two dollars why do I
remember that to the penny thirty years
later because there was so much stress
around that subject stress is a memory
inducer you'll remember things when
you're in high stress
in detail you notice not like when the
car wreck everything slows down it's the
same situation that's why your brain
works three and twenty two dollars
thirty years later I know what I spent
on this stupid air conditioner
fast forward a decade after that we're
making money again we've gotten the mess
cleaned up we're moving on with our
lives
we have an emergency fund of twenty five
thousand dollars same phone call to the
office naive that would be my wife the
air conditioners out again
now again means ten years later right
but the air conditioners out at the
house I called a heating and air guy
sent him over there he calls me back and
goes the whole thing's bad it needs to
be replaced and I said replace it I have
no idea what it costs I don't remember
you know why because a crisis becomes an
inconvenience when you have an emergency
fund that's tweetable right there okay a
crisis becomes an inconvenience when you
have an emergency fund so when you park
your emergency fund you park it where
you can get to it to fix the
transmission or replace the heating and
air and it becomes an inconvenience you
don't put it in a stupid CD a
certificate of depression to try to get
a quarter of a point more on your money
and then end up having to pay a penalty
to get your own money out they take a
portion of the very little interest that
they were giving you in the first place
to get your money out so just put it in
a simple savings account slash money
market account mine's in a money market
account got a money market account with
my mutual fund company and it's paying
nothing I don't know what it pays it's
like 1 1 a quarter maybe it's not if I
got one that pays 1.35 well who gives a
rip yes you're not getting rich on this
thing dude you're talking about what ten
one hundreds of a point here I mean it's
not you know you know not till one
hundred says one one hundredth of a
point shift here it's not that this is
not gonna a number of basis points it's
not gonna move the needle for you what
moves the needle is the fact you're
managing money properly you're not
having to touch the real investments
that are making Bank your good mutual
funds inside your 401k inside your Roth
IRA so don't try to worry about the
interest rate the only thing you want is
fully liquid meaning no penalties to get
to it do not hook it to the overdraft
protection on your checking account
because you might accidentally be buying
a couch and think that this is an
emergency
buying a couch is not an emergency I can
help you with that you might be thinking
that you know we need to go on a trip
and that's an emergency that is not an
emergency
it does not need to be hooked to the
overdraft protection checking you know
most of you have online banking and you
can actually jump online and move the
money over into your checking if you did
have truly an emergency and you needed
to cover something with a check you've
got time to do this everything's okay
there's very few things that you have
one hour to collect the money or you die
I mean that's just this is not a movie
this is their life it's real stuff here
so do not put it in overdraft protection
do not have your emergency fund where
there's a penalty to get it out and
don't spend like seven years of your
life researching trying to get 1/10 of
1% better interest rate who gives a rip
your emergency fund is not an investment
it is insurance and when you have
grandma's rainy day fund and place the
Gok fund the God Only Knows fund when
you have that in place it turns a crisis
into an inconvenience that's why it's
baby step three and the first thousand
of it is baby step one because it's
foundational for you to be able to build
out your house your financial house
think about it what if you had no
payments but a house payment think about
that no payments but a house payment and
fifteen thousand dollars cash in a
savings account by the way that would
put you in the top 10% of all Americans
that one thing all those two things a
fully funded emergency fund and no
payments but a house payment you know
why you
just me saying that
a sense of peace comes over you you know
why you that sense of peace comes over
you because it's correct it's
foundational it gives you a place to
build when you start trying to build
wealth while you're still broke you end
up stumbling around in the dark stubbing
your toe on the chair
[Music]
stop your 401k temporarily stop all
investing temporarily work through the
first through baby step three baby steps
$1,000 debt-free accept the house finish
your emergency fund at three to six
months of expenses it's foundational to
building wealth and to getting control
of your life this is the Dave Ramsey
show